une tournure inattendue ce soir dans les
négociations de paix sur la syrie pour
la première fois depuis le début du
conflit en 2011 un accord de cessation
des hostilités a été conclue à l'échelle
nationale ce conflit je vous le rappelle
a fait au moins 400 mille morts et forcé
des millions de personnes à l'exil
selon cette entente de munich les
hostilités pourrait cesser dans une
semaine
alors marie-eve on n'attendait pas grand
chose vraiment de cette rencontre
aujourd'hui et pourtant on aboutit à une
entente
on parle de cesser les hostilités ouais
une entente inattendu vous l'avez dit on
avait commencé cette rencontre à munich
sur un ton plutôt pessimisme après des
heures et des heures de négociations
on se serait entendu dans un premier
temps on parle d'abord de faciliter
l'accès à beaucoup plus des
d'humanitaire dès maintenant en priorité
on va viser les zones assiégées surtout
dans les banlieues de damas les villes
de madaya dont on a beaucoup parlé dans
la gutta orientale aussi pour ensuite
pouvoir élargir cette distribution des
aides humanitaires à des millions de
personnes qui sont dans le besoin
et pendant ce temps au cours de la
semaine à venir le conseil international
de soutien à la syrie va mettre entre
eux en oeuvre les modalités donc de
cette entente de cessation des
hostilités
je vous propose d'écouter le secrétaire
d'état américain john kerry qui prévient
quand même que tout ça va être très
difficile
alors voilà on entend le secrétaire à la
défense
le secrétaire john kerry qui dit que
c'est un conflit qui demeure très
violent que le niveau de violence
augmente avec beaucoup de terroristes
présents sur le terrain oui sur le
terrain la réalité est extrêmement
complexe donc il faut rester prudent et
encore bien des écueils qui pourrait
faire dérailler cette entente
voilà la grande question ce sera de voir
si tout le monde toutes les parties vont
respecter cette entente de cessation des
hostilités il ya énormément de joie
présent il ya la russie qui était aux
côtés de john kerry plus tôt aujourd'hui
il ya l'armée syrienne du gouvernement
de bachar al assad et toutes les milices
qui combattent à ses côtés les ministres
du hezbollah les milices iraniennes
aussi et puis ensuite il ya toute une
panoplie qu de groupes rebelles et c'est
important de mentionner que cette
entente de cessation des hostilités ne
tient pas compte du groupe armé état
islamique ni de jabba talent nostra qui
est affilié à al qaïda
c'est donc dire que les groupes pourront
toujours combattre ces deux
organisations
d'autres groupes terroristes aussi ce
qui veut dire que les combats ce n'est
pas terminé et ça ouvre la porte à
toutes sortes d'interprétations aussi
mais quand même c'est peut-être un pas
dans vers une paix possible merci
beaucoup marie-eve un signe d'espoir